pubs up and down the UK are facing a
battle to survive how often do you go to
the pub we used to go out more often but
now we have to limit because of the
expenditure I can't as much as I'd like
to you saw a lot years ago but
you have fun to do it anymore Rising
costs and the after effects of the
pandemic have taken a toll it's personal
than it was between covert it's tougher
now it's the cost of living crisis
basically sealed it speaks
in his spring budget the chancellor
announced a tax relief on draft drinks
first of August the duty on Craft
products in pubs will be up to 11 Pence
lower than the duty in supermarkets but
is this enough
from enforced closure to constant
reinvention this is how pubs across the
country are being impacted by the cost
of living crisis
[Music]
Fiona Vincent and her family have run
the Lion Pub in Bristol for 14 years
deep down I think because my
grandmother's always run pubs in fact my
great-grandmothers run pups as well
it almost felt like it was an
inevitability but now she's worried if
the pub will stay in business I know
often says you're doing a great job and
we do try very hard and people around
here try very hard to support us but
these costs are just so humongous that
it's like a massive Wave It's drowning
you
it's making me feel about
it and she's not the only one struggling
Pub numbers across the UK have been in
Decline for decades
but the energy crisis and the impact of
the pandemic have put more pressure on
the institutions than ever before
in December 2021 there were about 37 500
pubs in Britain
twelve months later more than 1 200 had
closed
all the utility bills went from being
like six seven hundred pound to being
over a grand and a half to Grand in
certain aspects I remember one bill
coming through and it were they were
charging me like three and a half Grand
Jordan Wallace used to run the railway
Pub in Doncaster until it closed in
October
the pub had been around since the late
19th century when it was built to
accommodate Britain's new national rail
network customers also facing the cost
of living crisis they haven't really got
the money to come out but no one's gonna
want to drink in a cold Pub even though
everything literally everything is
challenging at the moment Warwick
heskins runs the Catherine will in
Newbury last year he had to close his
other Pub due to spiraling costs things
since have not been easy the electricity
even here has gone up from 1200 pound to
a three and a half thousand pound a
month
and with gas and everything as well
going up food prices have gone
ridiculously high most of the drink
suppliers are putting all the beers
prices up by about 10 13 which you can't
pass fully on to the customers otherwise
you won't have any customers at all left
in the last few years
a year and why is that
um mainly the money yeah we got another
habit okay on the whole it's not as busy
to be honest last year the government
promised to help they introduced the
energy bill relief scheme which capped
gas and electricity prices for some
businesses a UK Hospitality survey has
found businesses expect an 82 rise in
their energy bills when the support is
reduced in April Fiona says it's been
impossible getting her hands on the
current relief you called so many people
so there was no real help about that so
I still don't really know what we should
be getting
you just have to keep improvising
Reinventing yourself very slightly and I
think that's quite shocking for some
people at least do chimichangas but we
can't afford to necessarily do that
because I don't know I'm from one minute
to the next whether we're going to be
busy or not over 4 800 licensed premises
closed last year due to the cost of
living crisis the vast majority that
went under from October to December were
independently owned no one's actually
looking at the individuals I think
they're not looking forward to the sort
of the structure of small businesses
being part of the community and we give
a lot here to people that don't see a
lot of people and lots of PODS do a
little social areas and you know that's
quite important to people what do you
think it is about the Great British pub
that I don't know it seems to have an
atmosphere all its own I like the social
science see I've got dreams
I like to chat with somebody I think
it's just an institution really isn't it
the British pump I mean everybody loves
a British pub